alors voilà en parlant d'histoire vous
avez un point commun avec michel
houellebecq nous avons reçus dans cette
émission il ya quelques semaines c'est
que vous pensez que la vague intégristes
va refluer vous dites dans dix ans dans
20 ans l'intégrisme musulman qui est
tellement fort aujourd'hui tellement
violent aujourd'hui va se calmer
pourquoi à votre avis je pense que c'est
un phénomène connaît tous et vous vous
êtes comme madame soleil vous connaissez
tous et je ne suis pas prophète
j'ai déjà eu pas mal de difficultés avec
les prophètes alors je ne surtout pas
prétendant être un modèle
mais si vous regardez les pays où le
l'intégrisme musulman a eu le plus de
deux fois ce sont les pays où justement
où l'islam est le moins aimé le lait les
afghans détestait les talibans les
iraniens aujourd'hui n'aime pas beaucoup
le gouvernement des ateliers en algérie
pendant la période du fils et du gia ses
pouvoirs et et était détesté donc
théorie mais j'apprécie c'est comme une
espèce de fièvre le fanatisme intègre il
ya eu les fanatiques dans toutes les
guerres il ya eu des fanatiques
est ce que j'arrive pas à comprendre
c'est qu'à chaque fois que vous sortez
un livre c'est sur le le fanatique
musulman musulmans musulmans de
musulmans musulmans pouvaient pas
changer de sujet de sani - voilà c'est
ça ils s'allient pour montrer comment un
musulman doux et gentil devient un
fanatique qui fait pas un livre sur les
musulmans sont fanatiques mais je viens
d'une famille musulmane
j'ai autant le droit de parler de
l'islam que n'importe qui alors pourquoi
vous n'avez pas répondu à la question
pourquoi l'islam intégriste va refluer
dans les années qui viennent d'après
vous à mon sens je crois qu'il y aura un
recul parce que dans les pays où l'islam
à et gagner le plus de pouvoir c'est
l'endroit où justement le peuple aime le
moins les kashmiri des tests en vol et
l'islam intégriste de même que les
afghans de même que les iraniens
donc ce que je dis c'est que c'est un
phénomène à court terme et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes
abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu